ciao ragazzi tornati sul nostro canale
sono contento finalmente di potervi
rivedere riparlare qui su youtube ci
siamo presi un po di tempo per mettere
in ordine le idee la cucina sta ancora
andando avanti quindi dovremo aspettare
ancora un po di tempo prima di partire
di nuovo con cucina mutata ma volevo
tantissimo far vedere la stanza in
bianco e nero del nostro studio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
prima di mostrare quello che è stato il
percorso infinito di mesi settimane che
ci hanno permesso di creare questa
stanza volevo ringraziare l'unico
oggetto che non è stato veramente un 23
set sin dall'inizio ma è questo
meraviglioso televisore all'interno del
quale mi trovo è fondamentale per noi
che lavoriamo col video avere uno
strumento che ci permetta di
effettivamente vivere il mondo del
in maniera il più possibile accurata
ecco perché ci tenevo a ringraziare per
averci mandato il loro ultimo il
televisore la 90 centrati serre ora
questo che bisogna potrebbe mandare devo
una stron ata in uno spazio e branding
però un paio di cose che a me sono
piaciute tantissimo ma di parte le cose
veramente rivoluzionato all'interessato
si è chiusa successivamente traffico è
fondamentale il nostro lavoro diventa
una lavagna interattiva per i nostri
meeting ci permette di garanzia la post
produzione di diventare
più assurda che per noi sono il
televisore e perfetta dell'immagine
proprio 2000
pranzo di stracciando predator atti in
esame per guardare in modo certo sarà
mancano tantissimo perché sony si sta
impegnando a ridurre bisogna inventare
in tutte quante le albe questo revisore
nella prova per esempio una delle
caratteristiche lottato tantissimo
quella di poter spegnere il monitor
l'ultimo le sue varie reti illuminazioni
che permetterà effettivamente un consumo
minore di tenere ancora non abbia acceso
in modo non consumare inutilmente una
roba che magari in quel momento mi stai
guardando mi stai seguendo e che sta
solamente ascoltando detto ciò grazie
amico sony ma arrivato il momento di
farvi fare un tuffo nel passato per
scoprire insieme a tutto quanto il team
come abbiamo messo in piedi questa
stanza per farlo cadere
allora questa quella stanza testo si
passa a posare
brava abbiamo nel video che l'operato
[Musica]
contento di vederti contento giammarco
[Applauso]
grazie
[Musica]
è questo qui è il risultato di realtà ci
sono presi un pochino di tempo per per i
piatti il resto dell'ufficio e adesso ho
deciso di riprendere per ultimare
positivamente la nostra meeting per
cominciare avremo assolutamente bisogno
di musica di un tavolo e soprattutto di
lavoratori adesso possiamo partire ogni
angolo stanno ripassando nero tutti
quanti sto facendo la stessa cosa con
gli oggetti reali e fisici all'interno
della stanza quindi le sedi e le porte
le finestre il termosifone il tavolo e
allo stesso tempo anche la lampada che
saranno gli unici oggetti reali
all'interno di questa la molla
per mar il cammino copiando ci pensa che
rispetto al televisore è la reflex che
ho scaricato per riuscire a di signa qua
questo quadro al televisore che tipo di
top di gamma migliore televisore mai
fatto ragioni che sono otto risposta di
dati uno è stato dato medio applicato
solo un
inizio
dei quadri di uno vicino tondo come
sopra quadrato
una via vai una pianta questa è la
responsabilità
che anche regia con banana si
inizia oggi
[Risate]
posso fare una critica a sony dove si
è lavorato molto intensamente perché
scena mariga
problema che tutto è affatto felice
capace batteristi della parola
si no
questa immobile di nonno che è stato un
reperto archeologico
che stava sul mobile di scolo entra
[Musica]
[Risate]
si
[Musica]
guardino mi dicono che l'invidia il
quadro
[Musica]
è pericolosissima sta cosa il rimedio
dell'opera d'arte attendiamo bloccare il
4 anni
possiamo andare
con un colpo di frusta mente raffinata
positivo dei fan lungo viaggio di
ritorno
[Musica]
reggono che è una bellezza macchina
dietro ecco
qualora dovesse succedere qualcosa
faranno disco
[Musica]
questo in realtà l'ha fatto nostro nonno
turn è rinato ma se sarà una rivolta
nella tomba però sarebbe firmerebbe
piero di quello che la famiglia ha
creato nonno questa è per terra
già martino
ora vediamo
[Musica]
tante di quelle pesciola the prenderlo
bianco e rifinitura qua vedete la
rifinitura guarda quanto è soddisfacente
il lavoro della rifinitura al mondo
ma insomma sei come se nel disegno ma si
può riparare
senso verrebbe fatto col grigio una
sedia
sto cercando di fare la parte artistica
perché sono la competenza ma queste cose
rebbero le competenze artistiche
l'unica nota positiva che siri poter
vincere di bianco
unanime sulla testa questa è una altezza
la mia mancano di certo
e sapete che cita la ciò suona cioè
quando sei in bolla
[Musica]
vice
campione
[Applauso]
dei pesi martella
guardate che dio da ecco
cosa in altro lavorarsi cominciare
l'idea riesca bene non un ed i movimenti
sono sulle spalle tra 20 giorni ma la
ghiera c'era mensola piro
è
[Risate]
ammessa senza gianmario per cammino
si fa pure questo lampadario un amante
del caso si
muove libris non meritano questo o
comparative che fa della nostra
grammatica mercati
[Musica]
è una merda questa cosa che l'ha fatto
il greco pi greco pi greco dichiarato mi
ricorda un pò y lo sai tu chiami
ricordano cappelle raga ma le mensole le
abbiamo tolte sono state buttate no no
prendi le mettiamo in quadri qua da
mentre insieme alle sue sei style walker
gare la striscia assolutamente le
produzioni hanno tutte un runner e
capire coletti corre in giro alessandro
il nostro strisce
blu non ne faccia del telefono
[Musica]
donna precisa che contiene quando avete
fatto e mensole mi sa che il 93 di
chi a milito
[Musica]
l'ossigeno quando movimento per la
striscia
omaggio alla citt rizza in maniera
impressionista
via del mare forzatissimo certo male a
mario
è il quadro più vuoto mi
ammazzo ai tensione ma nessuno l'artista
al confronto a quello che davvero
aver fatto cosa posso far diventare una
riga con il telefono a casa ea un tema
libri di grava e una testa di animazione
non so cosa c'entra la guardi dentro
di tutti quanti noi hinton però trici
abbassa fino nostra volta bassa
accumularlo bassa della gradevole e
armeno in terra
e non c'erano ciò che sa fare questa
stanza con cera che così sembra che i
delleani sono la patina del ristorante
di caps in questo quadro è proprio una
scena
[Risate]
troppo bene
insomma dopo ben
undici grasso guardami
un po
certo
[Musica]
normalità
la dottoressa joy elisa la ragazza con
l'orecchino di perla la scimmia con loro
[Risate]
a quello che il soggetto peggiore di
questa stanza
[Musica]
fa vedere non ci credo come fatto
fortuna consiglio a voi
andatevene buon dio solo pulire libere
favore lo riprendi guarda che fatta i
pantaloni
e questo è il modo in cui abbiamo messo
in piedi in questa stanza
adesso sono stati di judo giorni
settimane mesi di dolore fatica per un
risultato che
ci piace ma non affezionarsi troppo il
televisore potrebbe essere l'unica cosa
che rimarrà in piedi ovviamente non la
smantelleremo subito ci diamo un
traguardo se raggiungiamo 10 like a
questo video la smantelleremo ok
speriamo speriamo di non fregarci
non
sono stremato se io potessi tornare
indietro e farvi vedere la faccia che
avevo nel televisore mentre presentava
la stanza dei tristi un uomo finito
[Musica]